на стадію рокс української літератури
прийшла майже всі дуже шляхом про випускне
клас і х 24 to those that про повну
загальна середнього світла вранці out which
і більше дітей до дав дуже закупівля
ван їх територій вона до савангу криму і
game після основних зайняти чотири
випадало дістаньте ну зовсім нова форма
доповіді не з
багато хто дуже ми їх знаємо її стикуємося
текке
місцях обидва по телефону так і малювати
на початку літа ще живуть на ній
підконтрольних територіях розрубала
держава обі-ван і мало взуття сколу
середньому кошторис почали б спиш торн цієї
розумів уступу пробач потрібно вище за я
фотокопії документів
проте далеко не всі знають хто такий чоловік
рилися поставою свою 40 а river of
розвивається добре 11 клас snax криму 3
мою почет укривати не дістаньте не школі
йому український атестат переконаєте у 17
тисяч гривень праски ти зафіксував його
криму чіпляється з і таким вже випасти
розуму не дуже багато знаємо їх які вдові а
там вже і десятому класі та кімоно особливі
100 запитувати яхта рахунок і я яким від
і я його варю
оладки не може позиватися дозволить ще
поїхати за все гарне кішка з хлопцям
їх убором упускай пум без вигляду
проте ціни гаранту і bespeco знали тих
чим ми пишемо про контрольну роботу он і
все підібгати все продають у криму на
кожному інтернет провайдері стоїть чорно
screen до його не перевіряють куди заходять
швидкість цього че
одне із завдань окупаційної влади
криму зранку а ти молодий на території
by острова шкіра право замовлення нитки та
валентино там у радій вона ж маленькі
пори мазі так для кримчан міністерство
свитою фігура куб олег шила розум його в
ступу до суми українських вин 7 до 11
років неопрен x творять спеціальні центри
у них подібним dahon випускних будинок
з-під нової літератури тієї історії
україни моя можна весь обмінятися
російський атестат на українські тапу
дати документа всього ж vnc аттестат для
випускники до школи так званих днр і лнр
такий спосіб обмінятися
намажу його вони створили тло з творили
фейка в україну та піти фейковий україни
я своя історія
я історія днр їй історія лнр осі ox
гострим предметом роботи ми там робити
покаже міністерстві без нього вони
створив державну ти статтю випускники
окупованих територій може
виступати до евакуйованих vnc так їх
16 донбасу іуди ндс крим